la semaine prochaine en attendant on
vous souhaite une très belle année chez
olivier le dernier mot
le premier mot de l'année j'ai
l'impression que dans sa dernière
interview monsieur mac ronde de se poser
la question d'où va la france moi je
peux lui répondre dans le mur
et où vont les états unis ben
économiquement dans le mur aussi
bonne année tout de même
[Musique]
le doute plane encore sur la tenue de la
can 2022 au cameroun la caf réfléchirai
à annuler la compétition quelles sont
vos informations c'est clairement une
fake news aujourd'hui en afrique cette
campagne médiatique est vu comme un
sabotage pour cette can à 2022 les yeux
sont rivés sur le fameux stade de limbé
confronté à des retards de travaux et un
scandale financier présumé avec le
nouveau prélat la fécafoot nous savons
que les choses vont se passer pour
l'équipement c'est pas tous les pays
africains qui selon de désormais capable
d'organiser une canne à 24 équipes on ne
peut pas priver les africains d'europe
compétition phare la cale trois jours
cameroun et des buts et on a plus
janvier
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
plusieurs milliers de personnes réunies
aujourd'hui partout en france contre le
pass vaccinale antico vide de marseille
à strasbourg en passant par paris des
protestations qui globalement déroulé
dans le calme malgré quelques tensions
dans la capitale
encore
[Musique]
entretien téléphonique aujourd'hui entre
le président russe et son homologue
kazakh vladimir poutine et kassim jean
marc tokayev conviennent de rester en
contact permanent pour restaurer l'ordre
au kazakhstan pays d'asie centrale
ébranlé depuis une semaine par de
violentes manifestations
déclenchées par la hausse du prix du gaz
[Musique]
les états unis plus que jamais en proie
à la fracture raciale au lancement d'un
procès qui a vu la condamnation à la
prison à vie de trois hommes blancs
accusés d'avoir tué intérieur
afro-américains armes audard berri avait
vu son nom scandé lors des grandes
manifestations anti racistes qui avaient
secoué le pays 1 et et 2020
[Musique]
d
excellent week end à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue sur arte france pour une
nouvelle demi heure d'information
nouveau samedi de mobilisation plusieurs
milliers de personnes dans les rues dans
de nombreuses villes de france pour dire
non au pass vaccinale antico vide
protestation à strasbourg chambéry et
lyon marseille nantes ou encore toulouse
avec quelques tensions ont eu lieu dans
la ville rose entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre
sporadiques également entre policiers et
protestataires à paris où plusieurs
rassemblements ont eu lieu notamment
celui organisé par le président des
patriotes florian philippon entre le
palais royal et les invalides ou encore
un cortège emmené par les gilet jaune
plus d'explications avec estelle farges
qui a suivi cette journée de
mobilisation
les gilets jaunes ont déambulé pendant
près de quatre heures dans les rues de
la capitale ils se sont joints au
mouvement de protestation contre le pass
sanitaires et contre le pass vaccinale
ils manifestaient plus particulièrement
contre se passe vaccinale aujourd'hui
qui pourrait entrer en vigueur dès le 15
janvier prochain mais il y avait aussi
des revendications liées au début du
mouvement se propose d'écouter les
quelques gilet jaune avec qui nous avons
pu parler et notamment l'organisateur de
la manifestation d'aujourd'hui est
vraiment le pouvoir qui est en train de
mettre une pression contre les opposants
politiques et nous ici vous avez des
gens qui n'ont rien à gagner dans cette
lutte en termes financiers en termes de
postes on est là vraiment parce qu'on
est content ce gouvernement on n'a rien
à gagner et on est l'opposition les
gilet jaune et citoyens en colère et on
est toujours là plus on avance dans le
temps est en fait plus on nous prive de
liberté moi ça fait deux ans que je suis
en télétravail et
bah c'est long et ça suffit ça a choqué
une bonne partie de la france
qu'un président en fonction en mer d'une
partie de la population
et qu'il ira jusqu'au bout bien sûr mais
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout cabano le
message qu'on va lui faire passer c'est
que nous aussi on ira jusqu'au bout et
que nous aussi on va continuer à
emmerder et c'est ça la stratégie voilà
pour les revendications du côté du
cortège et bien vous pouvez peut-être le
voir derrière moi sur ces images de
didier mulot les manifestants sont
arrivés à place de la nation le lieu de
dispersion elle chiffre vient de tomber
à l'instant le ministère de l'intérieur
annonce que cent mille manifestants ont
participé à cette journée de
mobilisation un net rebond dont en terme
de participation une nouvelle
manifestation alors qu'à un nouvel
indicateur épidémique tombe également ce
soir il est toujours très élevé plus de
300 3000 nouveaux cas de covile 19 ces
dernières 24 heures et au delà du débat
lié au pass vacciner ce sont les
inquiétudes des manifestants liés au
vaccin y cohabitent qui cristallise les
peurs écoutez à ce sujet et m kanso
médecin infectiologue à l'hôpital
antoine béclère de clamart et rémi tales
fondateur du collectif peuple libre
s'il ya bien un jeu répète un produit de
santé qui a été testé qui ont été
testées sur des milliards de personnes
soit à l'heure actuelle c'est bien ces
vaccins anti qu'ovide je l'interromps
jamais sur les ondes de téléphones
portables je ne manquerai jamais sont
tous ces trucs là et en fait je
m'interroge maintenant parce que c'est
l'objet qui cristallise les
mécontentements sociaux et tous mes
peurs ancestrales et je vais de
cristalliser pour aller dire non le
vaccin alors que attention nous
annoncerons des 10 avec un schéma
vaccinal
ce n'est pas le seul élément nous avons
des médicaments qui vont commencer à
apparaître qu'ils vont nous aider ça ça
va permettre de
construire un consensus et à voir les
deux possibilités l'idée selon laquelle
la pédagogie suffirait à convaincre son
% la vaccination enfin la population de
se faire vacciner
et une dès
qu'ils quittent qui est injuste sur le
plan purement intellectuelle puisque
c'est faire fi des arguments solides
qu'ont certaines ory de la population
pour s'interroger sur le vaccin lorsque
jean marc sabatier qui d'un professeur
de médecine directeur de recherche au
cnrs publie un papier dans lequel il
montre que les rappels répétées d'un
même produit a fortiori arn messagers
peuvent contribuer à dérégler l'immunité
à favoriser peut-être sur le long terme
des maladies auto immunes ou des cancers
il est tout à fait sens et il est tout à
fait normal de s'interroger et c'est pas
en faisant la pédagogie on va lever ces
doutes qu'on va lever ses inquiétudes et
si le projet de loi sur le pass
vaccinale est examinée la semaine
prochaine par le sénat en france ce
laisser-passer controversé est déjà en
vigueur dans d'autres pays état des
lieux avec médias ce qui fit
au vatican depuis février 2021 le vaccin
est impératif les habitants qui ne sont
pas vaccinés risque une amende et même
un licenciement les italiens s'en passe
vaccinale au 15 février pourrait être
sanctionné d'une amende de 100 euros
même sanction pour les réfractaires
grecque avec une amende reconductibilité
tous les mois une sanction qui entrera
en vigueur à compter du 16 janvier
en autriche les non-vaccinés devront
payer une amende de 600 euros tous les
trois mois somme qui peut aller jusqu'à
3600 euros en cas de non paiement ils
ont jusqu'au 15 mars pour se mettre en
règle
au canada les autorités fédérales ont
suspendu les allocations chômage aux non
vaccinées depuis le 2 janvier le québec
va plus loin le ministre de la province
francophone a annoncé que les commerces
vendant de l'alcool et du cannabis
seront accessibles seulement aux
citoyens qui détiennent un passeport
vaccinable une mesure qui sera mise en
place à partir du 18 janvier à singapour
les non vaccinés qui sont admis en soins
intensifs devront eux-mêmes financer le
coût de l'hospitalisation
estimé à 16 mille deux cents euros
dans certaines régions indonésiennes les
personnes qui refusent d'injection
s'expose à un refus de délivrance du
permis de conduire certains districts
supprime les aides sociales ou empêchent
l'arrivée de courrier utile pour
commencer un nouvel emploi au pakistan
dans la province du pendjab les
autorités locales peuvent aller jusqu'à
bloquer les cartes sim des non vaccinés
un véritable handicap dans un pays où
l'accès à internet se fait
majoritairement à partir de son
téléphone portable
et l'icône des antilles vax novak
djokovic le numéro un mondial de tennis
demandent à quitter l'hôtel de melbourne
en australie où il est retenu le serbe
dit être exemptés de vaccination après
avoir contracté le corps en habit russe
le 16 décembre problème il est apparu
publiquement sans masque lendemain lors
d'un rassemblement à belgrade cas au
combat
ils sont toujours plusieurs dizaines à
réclamer la libération de novak djokovic
cela fait désormais trois jours que le
numéro un mondial a été placé en centre
de rétention dans un hôtel de melbourne
au milieu d'autres migrants arrivés
illégalement sur le territoire en cause
l'annulation de son visa au motif qu'il
ne remplissait pas les strictes
conditions d'entrée sur le territoire
c'est la fédération australienne de
tennis l'instance organisatrice de
l'open d'australie qui est accusé
d'avoir induit les joueurs en erreur
concernant les obligations en matière de
vaccination contre locaux vides 19 pour
rentrer dans le pays ce dont se défend
son président on pointe beaucoup du
doigt et on blâme beaucoup mais je peux
vous assurer que notre équipe a fait un
travail incroyable
nous comprenons la situation actuelle et
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec novak et son équipe
ainsi qu'avec d'autres personnes et
leurs équipes qui se trouvent dans cette
situation
dans une note envoyée aux joueurs
l'organisation du tournoi assure qu'une
personne ayant récemment contracté le
coït 19 peut bénéficier d'une exemption
de vaccination ce qui est le cas de
novak djokovic selon ses avocats dans
une déclaration publiée aujourd'hui il
affirme que le champion serbe aurait
contracté le qu'ovide 19 le 16 décembre
dernier et devrait donc avoir droit à
une exemption problème le gouvernement
australien a assuré avoir prévu la
fédération dès novembre que cette
disposition n'était valable que pour les
résidents australien et non pour les
citoyens étrangers une incompréhension
qui coûte cher à novak djokovic mais
également à plusieurs autres athlètes
dans le même cas
la star du tennis mondial a de son côté
tenu à saluer ses fans pour leur
mobilisation
merci aux gens du monde entier pour
votre soutien continu je peux le sentir
et je l'apprécié grandement le
dénouement de la sphère devrait
intervenir ce lundi avec l'examen par un
tribunal fédéral de la requête déposée
par ses avocats contre son expulsion du
territoire le numéro un mondial devrait
alors savoir s'il peut briguer un 21e
titre du grand chelem record absolu
devoir quitter l'australie
précipitamment en inde les cas de kobe
19 augmente de façon exponentielle les
nouvelles contaminations doublé en deux
jours le système de santé indien est
sous tension en raison de la
transmissibilité élevé du variant
omicron et rémy savary un rideau tiré
une dernière fois
à partir de ce samedi matin seuls les
travailleurs essentielles peuvent se
rendre sur leur lieu de travail un
nouveau coup dur pour certains secteurs
professionnels comme ce propriétaire
d'une société de taxis pour qui ce
confinement est un nouveau coup de
massue
je dirige une entreprise de location de
taxi qui est gravement touchée par le
coronavirus j'avais dit taxi mais j'en
ai vendu 8 il ne m'en reste plus que
deux car nous ne pouvons pas rembourser
les prêts je ne peux donc pas payer des
frais de mon ménage je ne sais pas
comment gérer tout cela
aujourd'hui encore il y a un look
d'homme qui arrivent mais nous sommes
déjà ruiné
alors qu'un couvre-feu était déjà en
vigueur de 22 heures à 6 heures du matin
la capitale indienne passe à la vitesse
supérieure face à un variant omicron qui
connaît une propagation exponentielle
ces dernières 24 heures plus de 17 mille
nouveaux cas ont été recensés
rien que dans cette ville de 25 millions
d'habitants un niveau élevé le plus haut
depuis le 8 mai dernier new delhi mais
également bombay bangalore ont décidé de
serrer la vis en imposant des
restrictions nocturne pour les trois
plus grandes villes du pays et leurs 43
millions d'âmes cumuler le traumatisme
de la deuxième vague est encore dans
tous les esprits avec ses crématorium à
ciel ouvert entre avril et juin plus de
200 mille personnes avaient perdu la vie
des suites du virus les cas de korn
virus étant en augmentation ce
confinement est indispensable pour mon
entreprise les deux dernières années
nous avons subi des pertes et nous
subirons les mêmes
nir je serais heureux lorsque le nombre
de cas de covin 19 sera plus faible et
qu'il n'y aura pas de confinement si
pour le moment aucune durée assez
restriction n'a été communiquée c'est
bel et bien une nouvelle vague
épidémique qui s'est abattue sur l'inde
menaçant un système de santé déjà très
fragilisée pour certains ces mesures
arrivent trop tard la troisième phase du
virus a commencé le couvre-feu du
week-end est peut-être un peu retardé
peut être d'une semaine de deux semaines
peut être aurions nous pu le faire un
peu plus tôt nous avons attendu trop
longtemps la deuxième vague était
mauvaise et nous n'aurions pas dû
attendre trop longtemps
si plus d'un milliard et demi de doses
ont aujourd'hui été administrés seuls
45% de la population indienne présente
aujourd'hui un schéma vaccinal complet
alors que plus de 60 % d'entre elles a
reçu au moins une dose le gouvernement
entend bien intensifier sa politique de
vaccination de la semaine prochaine la
campagne de rappel pour les plus de 60
ans débutera depuis lundi dernier ce
sont les adolescents de 15 à 18 ans qui
doivent affronter d'aiguilhe plus que
jamais le pays semble mettre tous les
moyens en oeuvre pour ne pas revivre la
catastrophe sanitaire de mai dernier
entretien téléphonique tout à l'heure
entre le président russe et son
homologue kazakh vladimir poutine etc à
sinjar tokayev conviennent de rester en
contact permanent pour restaurer l'ordre
au kazakhstan pays d'asie centrale
ébranlé depuis une semaine par de
violentes protestations en est de la
hausse du prix du gaz moscou qui a
apporté son aide avec l'envoi de troupes
de maintien de la paix soutient qu'ils
passent mal à du côté de washington la
correspondance en russie dans l'omc les
roues
dans cette conversation le président
kazakh a décrit en détail l'évolution de
la situation sur place une situation qui
d'après lui tend à se stabiliser à ce
titre il a remercié les dirigeants des
autres pays qui composent l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective à
savoir l'arménie la biélorussie le
kirghizstan la russie et le tadjikistan
il a particulièrement salué la limousine
pour l'aide militaire apportée ces
dernières 48 heures une aide militaire
qui a contribué à rétablir l'ordre dans
la capitale kassim jomart tokayev a
estimé qu'il était nécessaire de tenir
prochainement une réunion conjointe
entre les dirigeants des pays de
l'organisation d'une compétition validé
par vladimir poutine même si à l'heure
actuelle aucune date n'a encore été
retenue à la suite de cette conversation
le président russe a eu au téléphone
d'autres dirigeants des pays membres de
l'organisation régionale afin d'évoquer
le dossier kazakh à noter que l'ancien
président noursoultan nazarbaïev qui a
été et quartier de ces derniers jours du
conseil de sécurité nationale qui
dirigeait depuis son départ du pouvoir
et bien cet ancien président a appelé la
population à se rassembler autour du
président pour surmonter cette crise et
parallèlement dans le contexte des
émeutes qui ont secoué le pays le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
organise des vols de rapatriement à
destination des ressortissants russes
depuis almaty tu la capitale économique
du kazakhstan et c'est dans cette ville
que les limites ont été les plus
violentes et santé un calme précaire
dans les rues d'almaty la capitale
économique du kazakhstan où les soldats
russes de maintien de la paix tu tombes
de sécuriser un certain nombre de sites
stratégiques oil gas edf envoyé spécial
pour arte international a pu suivre
l'une de leurs missions
c'est probablement la partie la plus
dangereuse du voyage des soldats de
maintien de la paix on se dirige dans la
ville d'almaty qui est probablement la
zone la plus dangereuse du kazakhstan
actuellement une partie de la ville est
toujours sous contrôle des bande de
maraudeurs de pillards de personnes
armées jusqu'aux dents qui ont déjà
attaqué des camions et des
infrastructures militaires
saisi des armes à feu y compris des
armes d'assaut et qui sont connus pour
harceler les personnes les passagers et
les véhicules qui entrent dans la ville
selon le gouvernement kazakh qui a
demandé de l'aide aux soldats de la paix
leur mission consiste à prendre sous
leur contrôle une infrastructure
stratégique vital dans la ville dont un
établissement d'enseignement supérieur
militaire un établissement
d'enseignement et c'est là où nous nous
dirigeons
ouais
heureusement le voyage s'est déroulé
sans incident on n'a vu aucun signe de
violence ou des foules qui rôdent dans
la ville il y avait très peu de gens
dans les rues il n'y a tout simplement
aucun endroit où aller la plupart des
entreprises sont fermées les magasins
ont été pillés et les gens ont peur de
se déplacer inutilement alors que les
soldats de maintien de la paix ont été
autorisés à utiliser leurs armes en
légitime défense de nombreux
responsables ont déclaré que les soldats
de maintien de la paix ne serait pas là
pour rétablir l'ordre leur mission
consistera principalement à surveiller
de nombreux sites ce qui permettra aux
troupes casaque de rétablir l'ordre dans
les zones troublées
[Musique]
l'aéroport d'almaty est l'un des
premiers endroits que les soldats de la
paix de l'hôtesse et ont aidé à
sécuriser et à protéger tout d'abord
parce que c'était la demande du
gouvernement du kazakhstan mais aussi en
raison de son importance stratégique
selon certaines informations des milices
aurait tenté de s'emparer de l'aéroport
et laure est endommagé ces informations
se sont avérés être fausse l'aéroport
est sécurisé et accueille désormais de
plus en plus de soldats de maintien de
la paix qui sont eux-mêmes sur la pointe
des pieds ils ont bien conscience qu'il
existe des gens prêts à organiser des
provocations des actes de violence pour
discréditer les soldats de la paix
leur mission consiste donc à sécuriser
et à protéger
et arrestations aujourd'hui pour haute
trahison de l'ex chef du renseignement
cas à zac ce qui prouve selon etienne
combière rédacteur en chef de novastar
médias spécialisés sur les centrales
quelques extensions de trouver
rapidement un des coupables on a
vraiment une situation qui est très
différente aujourd'hui entre almaty et
le reste du pays il ya une détermination
de l'administration tokayev a essayé de
trouver des coupables a des
répercussions en cascade des
manifestations très violentes à almaty
la capitale économique pour autant
aujourd'hui on a du mal à faire
exactement le le comment dire la
distinction entre les affirmations du
président et la réalité à savoir
effectivement une situation qui
s'envenime très très rapidement à almaty
le 5 janvier alors qu'auparavant entre
le 2 et le 5 janvier on a une manie des
manifestations certes importante mais
qui ne sont pas aussi violente et
aujourd'hui donc un comme vous
l'expliqué dans le sujet à une situation
qui est relativement calme dans le dans
le pays mais encore une fois on retrouve
cette distinction entre la capitale
économique et les autres j on a
d'ailleurs d'autres manifestations qui
sont encore en cours de manière
pacifique à jana ozenne et dans d'autres
villes actuellement au kazakhstan
l'amérique plus que jamais confrontés à
la fracture raciale au lendemain de la
condamnation à la prison à vie de trois
hommes blancs accusés d'avoir tué un
afro-américain art mode art berri avait
vu son nom scandé lors des grandes
manifestations anti raciste qui avait
secoué les états unis il ya un an et
demi
anthologie
le slogan blacklight matters condé pour
défendre la mémoire damodar brille un
jeune afro américain abattu par balles
alors qu'il faisait un jogging près de
chez lui dans la commune de brunswick en
géorgie à l'intérieur du tribunal
grégory mcmichael son fils travis
mcmichael et leurs voisins williams
brian attente de la sentence les trois
hommes sont longtemps passent entre les
mailles de la justice se réclamant d'une
ancienne loi géorgienne qui permet à de
simples citoyens de procéder à une
interpellation il aurait de plus
bénéficié de la complaisance d'un
concurrent local dans cet état
conservateur encore marquée par le
spectre de la ségrégation mais depuis
leurs arrestations et condamnations pour
meurtres le 24 novembre dernier la
clémence n'est plus de mise
amo d'art de riz a ensuite été
pourchassés et a battu et il a été tué
parce que des individus ici dans cette
salle d'audience ont pris la loi entre
leurs mains
et après la chute d'un mode arbres y les
mcmichael ont tourné le dos c'est à
nouveau une image troublante et ils se
sont éloignés c'était un meurtre c'est
est impitoyable et cela s'est produit en
ce qui concerne la cour sur la base des
preuves parce que la confrontation était
recherché
le père et son fils sont désormais fixés
ils passeront le reste de leur vie en
prison tandis que leurs voisins qui les
avait aidés à prendre le jeune homme en
tenaille devra attendre 30 ans avant de
pouvoir espérer une libération anticipée
une délibération qui intervient dans un
contexte particulièrement tendu où le
débat sur le racisme et l'autodéfense
font rage notamment après laffaire
georges floyd qui avait ébranlé le pays
en 2020 en sortant du tribunal la
famille s'est félicité de cette décision
de juste
ma prière était d'obtenir justice pour
un mode il s'est battu pour nous dans
les tribunaux il nous a donné un juge
équitable le juge aux âmes slip il a
entendu les témoignages de chacun d'eux
chaque témoin il nous a donné un très
bon verdict et il nous a donné une très
bonne sentence quand je suis entré dans
la salle d'audience le 5 octobre le 18
octobre je me suis assis dans cette
salle d'audience pendant cinq semaines
d'affilée mais je savais que nous
sortirions victorieux je n'en ai jamais
douté et je savais que ce jour viendrait
[Musique]
en février dernier à meaux d'arbres y
alors âgé de 25 ans était sorti de chez
lui pour faire un jogging l'accusant
d'être un cambrioleur grégory mcmichael
en grain son fils et son voisin pour le
prendre en chasse après une altercation
c'est le fils qui tuera le jeune
joggeurs de trois balles de fusil la
dimension raciale de cette affaire a été
sous jacente durant tout le procès et
pour l'avocat de la victime la sentence
énoncé marque un tournant historique de
la lutte antiraciste aux états unis
en amérique toujours mais en amérique du
sud nouvelle manifestation au chili une
protestation contre l'appel d'offres du
gouvernement pour l'exploitation privée
des réserves de lithium une décision du
président conservateur sortant sebastian
pinera qui ravive le débat sur la
nationalisation des réserves du pays
sébastien rabat
ce samedi les mineurs chiliens ont
quitté leur poste pour les rues de
santiago une manifestation accueillie
par les canons à eau et les unités anti
émeutes les protestataires ont fustigé
la décision du gouvernement d'autoriser
l'exploitation du lithium abondant dans
les sols chilien par des entreprises
étrangères
nous sommes ici pour défendre le cuivre
le lithium et l'or pour le chili pour le
peuple pour les travailleurs pour les
communautés pour le respect du chili
pour l'eau aussi est pour les différents
peuples qui habitent ces territoires
je suis extrêmement préoccupé car
l'extraction du lithium impute
l'installation de marais salants dans le
nord du chili
donc mon attention et d'exprimer de
manière ouverte et clair mon opposition
à ce que le lithium soit exploitée par
les sociétés transnationales accueilli
le lithium devrait appartenir aux
chiliens ont sus je demande que
l'extraction du lithium soit durable
avec une politique minière poste
extraction c'est un espace où cohabitent
de nombreuses espèces migratrices
un projet cher au président sortant du
centre-droit sebastian pinera celui ci
avait enclenché en octobre dernier ce
processus qui dans les faits pourraient
permettre aux plus offrants d'exploiter
jusqu'à 400 mille tonnes de lithium pour
une durée de 7 ans reconductible un
appel d'offres dont la tenue devrait
être ratifié ou non à la fin du mois de
janvier nous avons deux options soit
nous laissons le lithium dans le sol
soit nous mettons le lithium à profit
pour tous les chiliens après avoir
constaté que la production de lithium
avait stagné au chili et que des pays
comme l'argentine et la bolivie menaçait
de dépasser le chili nous avons décidé
de lancer un plan stratégique
d'utilisation du lithium
le chili concentre à lui seul 50 7 % des
réserves mondiales du précieux métal
notamment utilisé pour la fabrication de
batteries le lithium pourraient doper le
marché des voitures électriques
une révolution qui n'a pas encore eu
lieu dans le pays
le président de gauche fraîchement élu
gabriel borique prendra ses fonctions au
mois de mars et porte les espoirs de ses
électeurs il a ainsi exprimé son désir
d'éviter de reproduire les erreurs
passées concernant la privatisation des
ressources du pays et a proposé la
création d'une société nationale du
lithium une nationalisation qui pourrait
ne pas être au goût des marchés
financiers
leur retour en france avec leurs amis
chatte finalement arrivé tout à l'heure
à paris après sa libération toujours
plus tôt en egypte où il était détenu
depuis juillet 2019 coordinateur d'un
mouvement de boycott contre israël ce
militant politique pro palestinien était
accusée d' assistance à un groupe
terroriste et pour obtenir sa liberté à
misrata a été contraint de renoncer à sa
citoyenneté égyptienne il s'est exprimé
sur ses conditions de détention dès son
arrivée à l'aéroport de roissy aux côtés
de son épouse
c'est énorme je suis très heureux d'être
ici
j'ai passé les deux dernières années et
demie entre des prisons des lieux de
disparition forcée certains sous terre
d'autres à l'isolément
d'autres encore où j'étais avec
énormément de monde soumis à un
traitement particulièrement inhumain
ils m'ont accusé de beaucoup de choses
et ils m'ont dit un jour vous êtes
accusé de faire partie d'une
organisation terroriste
j'ai demandé aux gars
quelle était cette organisation
terroriste et il a dit eh bien nous
n'allons pas vous le dire
c'est la fin de cette édition se
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes à
21h et alors
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times le washington post the
world
girls go
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian